just white guys to know I've been
grinding for three hours but d-roc
overslept so wasn't documented you're
not my hustle d-roc
with my hustle d-roc man
it's a nice to have a neighborhood
that's him
Oh yep all right good luck Thanks
they know no feeling really good I
talked to him about that I talked about
musically and then I looked at him and I
said you just got more value on this
scope in the last hour than you
different a year didn't you and he
looked at me and said that's why I'm
here
I'm being selfish with this piece of
content I want to I want to point to
this piece of content my whole life
because it gets brought up every so
often and and I just want to clear it
forever like just zero zero zero intent
to tell people that this is the way you
have to do it I have no interest none
zero for you to do it my way I'm not
trying to tell you how to do it I'm just
trying to tell you how I do it so that
you can use it as a Northstar to proxy
and you should navigate around it you
know you're only getting truly exposed
now to how much work it really is to how
hard I really go and and I get that it's
intense and I get that it's exhausting
and I get that it could be boring and
mundane well guess what that's what it
is it's a constant grind it is forever
grinding day in and day out same [ __ ]
pound it problems meetings every day
always forever I'm sorry I can't show
you a lot of looks good I have some good
news there's some new looks coming he
rocks about the travel hits off with me
on this book tour and you know what
you're going to see in Australia and you
know we're going to see in all these
other places the same the grind the
hustle
Mike just trying to always move the ball
you know I mean trying to get a past
goal line and if not just make sure we
moved it meetings that are complete
waste of time or devastating and so I
feel like we're not getting anywhere
I get rogue I get angry and I just try
to move the ball like make sure that we
only have one more meeting after this
because that's it just no tolerance
super-pumped - uh - my first TV spot or
the new book I think I think this airs
on the Vega book comes out you know but
there could be breaking news gonna do
dr. oz show my jam how do you talk to an
angel thank you
we're going to take me right back oh
okay
I'm excited it's a different audience
you know it's a lot of daytime watching
stay-at-home types you know will be
really interesting to see how they
consume the energy the content and the
and the strategy so they're really doing
right by me three segments have to show
to be pretty good my mom's pumped that
always makes me happy so see what we do
Darren McGavin
Rob I'm here with you today again I
understand for a few minutes in the
audience a moment yeah and then the next
Thursday and you forgot this segment
right the bottom line is there's so much
to being perfect it's gonna sexy grind
the intermedius future home in July what
is that your cinematography getting it
is you he paired you hate it
anchor has been super super buggy for me
so just testing if it works Michael and
crew I love the Jersey New York hustle
but telling you right now if this
doesn't work I'm already pissed
random statement on anchor mainly
because I don't think it's going to work
because I just tried to do a test and
didn't [ __ ] work so what do I want to
say I peed my bed until I was 12
random fun fact 12 years old it almost
like a grown man at that point I'm still
peeing my bed in the middle of night
think about that and I turned out ok so
don't be scared about what happens in
the first 10 years of your life
spykor I just have a real quick question
is your real name Spiker because if it
is I'm really pissed because if my name
was spiked or Vaynerchuk I think I'd be
at least 4x more successful let me know
if your real name Spiker I'm just I
really don't think it is but if it is
anchor could be dangerous preventing
speculation is owning your medium in
this world you know what I mean like I
doing picky moving you around yeah me to
the lobby here yeah
fail right here yeah [ __ ] you right now
you know you yes game yes game huh
I'm Ricky go in there just wanted to
strategize about Bob draw one what I
mean without is something gets canceled
this is on your priority list
yawning hey yep okay that's a little
different but I was flabbergasted
interesting right yeah Matt oh we're
waiting I want away from our school here
yes just because like you're gonna see
this it's 90 minutes now I know what
that is okay cool with this Monday yeah
mm-hmm nice boss you need to be there is
the chief brand officer this year oh
what's that dude yeah okay cool that's
it thank you sir get to wine library
we'll film it like 145 to work and then
we need it unless in there yeah you have
to turn around right down in there we do
note it we do know everything that's the
beauty of Wine Library TV episode 1001 I
mean I'm coming to wine library tomorrow
tap to film episode 1001 because it's
the ten year anniversary of Wine Library
TV on Sunday cool so I'll see you around
1:30 I'm bringing Mischa - hello
everybody and welcome to Wine Library TV
I am your host gary vay-ner-chuk and
this my friends is the Thunder Show aka
the Internet's most passionate wine
program do are you band sorry
hold on one sec I mean it is that policy
we just had to talk I screwed up
why'd you why why did you why were you
late I was I was in a meeting late last
night
in a meeting yes and I snapped my words
not a reason to impress me yes and
instead you failed me avail we could use
these you know good rebounder yeah
Caillat hybrid hey everybody wants five
minutes like they think it's nothing
like five minutes is a lot around here
Joe let's get back a swoosh I hope
you're having a great day thanks are
only five minutes guys there was
something I wanted to like okay which is
like this common thing like what is it
except yes yes cool
Zack did you notice that did you notice
on my page to see a day trade attention
and Bill businesses scroll down guy
rebuilds businesses all the businesses
cool businesses and businesses and
businesses and businesses business is
impinge come that's a new audio track by
the way we're gonna do more knows I'm
just like fun to see when I'm all the
other way just start doing or knows sits
here yeah what but sits here I see him
later all right get out of here sorry
you just said you wanted me to have a
good day you did you just know I'm gonna
leave that here I've got the timestamp
on that it was literally 20 seconds
lunch with you for great any any tell
them thanks I'm on the shack podcast
okay and tell them what oh what we did
know we're not this is the 29th of
February we have to go through April
brother but I don't know there's a lot
of I'm not in the zone right now I know
you're like super pumped about us yeah
I'm going to type in our but you put up
Cleveland right you're to Australia to
Cleveland yes Robert how long am i there
really eight hours go back oh it's like
11 hours but go to the next day though I
mean the previous day so it's longer
than eight hours
nice are we doing something in Honolulu
like a meet-up
Club good I think banner programmatic
ads are worse than television I truly
believe that banner ads on websites are
a bigger blind spot than a commercial on
TV agree I don't think it's even close
yeah do you rock can you catch that
audio-wise
good cuz I want to make a video about
that you like analogies me I only I live
on them it's literally my I would say
it's my core way to communicate to the
world it's probably also why did well
with Twitter it like fit that kind of
form of communication oh I'm so excited
to read this yeah you'll like it because
it's not a technology book it's just a
360 entrepreneurial mindset botos love
being so light talk to you there hey you
ready I am I know I'm preaching I'm just
kind of like reinventing myself that's
my belief
great again the good news is unlike most
places you've probably worked in your
life you don't need to fight for it okay
it's it's literally what I'm sitting
here telling you is about to happen
you're in my head before I even do it
good good that's what I try to do go say
well coming to London on Alex March 23rd
March 23rd I don't know my schedule oh
cool sup everybody it's gary
vay-ner-chuk my book drops today on 97 9
the box ishmael what's up man it's Gary
Vee thank you so much for the Spanish
subtitles the Ishmael you literally
unlocked an entire entire different
subset of individuals who would never
know what I'm up to or what I'm talking
about thank you so so so so so so so
much what's up social media managers
it's me Gary Vaynerchuk leave it leave
it because we want to leave it and I can
talk yeah
talk about it okay hello how are you
recently Garrett you just watched it
together yes yeah great so I could just
talk talk about it got it
let me take a step back so I think this
is the television and I think this is
the radio and I think today is 1965 and
I believe it with every piece of my
heart and I believe that Facebook and
snapchat and Instagram and YouTube are
ABC NBC and CBS in 1965 and I think what
our job as a company is to help and and
become mash and Seinfeld and dynasty
right that's how I see the world if you
think about the great filmmakers or you
know the people that produce music
videos they had a style right it wasn't
they didn't patent anything it was a
style I want our style to be really good
in stories that are as long as they need
to be to be told that's it
that's the only thing I care about and
as your ID ating and I don't know who's
the equipment manager and who's but I
don't even I don't even know any of the
titles yet of like what this is supposed
to be but I want everybody here
regardless of what you do to be thinking
about that that when you see something
in your day-to-day as a normal human
that made you like interested or
intrigued you need to think about why
that happened and can that be applied
for us to create the cadence in the
style of the modern day commercial cool
any questions actually that might be fun
do we have a few minutes doing it no all
right good to see you thanks guys we
have a meeting yeah great let's do it
yeah there we go
good to see you again likewise hey VI
great you're blind charge such a
pleasure huh thank you
smells good in here a lot of good
Cologne or something I'm excited that's
must be him it's the bestest room smell
than year honey is it awful I think he's
your can you see I don't think so
they're always here smells like now it's
not tremendous
so what's a real pleasure I have to
perform I'm performing okay if I don't
perform I don't I have nothing to eat at
the end of the month extremely difficult
nowadays to bring the new fashion breath
especially because everything is already
in the market existing you cannot come
in with something new so at the end of
the day what are we selling we're
selling emotion we selling dreams we're
setting a lifestyle we're setting a
concept but we don't do it for money we
do it for for innovation for passion and
father's legacy this entire company
wants to figure out how to communicate
on this so we think that this is the
television and the television is the
radio and so we think Facebook Twitter
snapchat Instagram and YouTube is like
ABC NBC CBS the big networks in the
early days of television and then what
we do is whether or whether it's fashion
brand we want to be the number one show
on those platforms and that's all we
spend our time on nothing else because
that's how you make money when you don't
waste it
we'll talk we'll talk we'll talk yeah
hangers gotta talk to you let's go fine
if you're dying and I can ride Jim yes
no but I look right now I don't not off
the top of my head but I don't know
anything about it what
the third the third one's the most
interesting for me hey Casey how are
things could see again
Aria really good if I was to argue that
the video we make just happens to be a
funny video about how rad your sales
people are and the KPI and the Facebook
ad is actually a phone transaction so it
skips the steps that you guys normally
play in as long as that actually at the
end of the day leads to a better or
equal metric to the site traffic even
though I'm eliminating it because I know
what these guys magic can be and I also
know the code I don't know the culture
but I at least know the general sense of
the vibe here great alright thanks guys
I'm gonna seem to say have a great
weekend brother fricassee yeah no
worries
hey sorry how are you good to see you
that's fun till we got serious inside
yeah of course
I'm not gonna run because I don't want
to run like I need to do a call but like
hey Maxum mom and went really well you
can watch some of the footage on
dailyvee 16 that's going to be on a
couple days all right I gotta go I love
you guys but that wine you just bought I
love the idea of like doing it to my
list next week all right man talk
five birthday yeah it's cool right so
pumped ten years ago if you told me in
ten years I'd go from the $300 camera
from Best Buy with no lighting in my
office on this new thing called YouTube
to you following me around
that's me dead hey guys you following me
around you following me around every day
and putting out business content an
interesting decade just feels good
Nate you're not going to be proud of
yourself when we go you're not going to
be proud of yourself when we go lifting
next time and I dominate you all right
noted mentally prepare for discipline
Hey hi can you hear us now
yeah yeah we can do we always heard you
we always saw you we know everything can
you guys hear us
awesome great do you guys want to go
through the questions that you sent over
first and then we'll riff off of
anything off of those questions I think
we have something that's like doable but
I'll just show you it and I think yes um
the computer no it's okay it's uh you
need to have a great computer
well it's due up in the summer do you
want to speed that up it's okay did you
understand that like you being slow for
like seven minutes is probably less
value I'll get freezes like once a boy
so you're fine yeah it's good time so
done and you're value time I think we
already should have bought a new
computer in the last format it doesn't
warn me trying to die yeah um I'm
killing ourselves yeah I think we got
like two more minutes
yeah nothing's weird it's not weird it's
bad weird and bad are two different
things here have a great weekend Ari
I have a contact in you you were you me
email me there for that okay so I worry
my friend I'm good how are you it's good
to see you
did you hear uh did you hear that I'm
coming up the babson it looks like no I
mean it's gonna be a Babson event is it
yep
yeah because I Alex and I were talking
about it yesterday and then he got an
email from someone's come happen Bob
since it's happening okay awesome it
it's great to see you man and I'll see
you I'll see you uh I'll see you March
9th or 10th I'm gonna definitely do it
yes
Steph like it happens yeah like Thunder
somebody says about that hi brother yeah
yeah can you email me before the end of
the weekend three your your personal
opinion on the three things that are
movable you know what I mean I do cool
Andy super eight events this is a $31
that unit right now okay
I'm excite about the poster school okay
ready no no but you're coming right
you didn't you're the only one didn't
except now right all right Jesus
cuz you're eating pizza like savages
right around Christmas when she's like
all right so Babson's locked in could be
what I mean
alright later dude go on the frontier
and so please please please please
understand that I don't want anybody to
do it my way I'm not showing you how
cool I am with my work ethic I'm not
trying to impose my will go do this I'm
not trying to take away from your family
time or your downtime I'm just
desperately trying to share my reality
and my truth and because I learn by
watching others oh by the way I mainly
learned by watching others of what I
don't want to do or how I want to do a
difference not how I want to do it and
so I guess for me I've bought into
showing you the kind of naked truth of
the 24/7 365 hustle and and and that's
it you know I actually secretly don't
want anybody to do it because I know my
advantage is that I outwork every single
one of you and so I you know some of you
are so much more talented than I am some
of you are are better at building
infrastructure around you most of you
have no interest in this 24/7 work ethic
but please please please also don't be
confused I'm not sad I'm not upset I
love the bed that I made for myself I
sleep in a cozy every second and so it
works me doesn't necessarily work for
you I do me you do you but please never
for the rest of my life no matter how I
roll no matter what I put out no matter
where I put it out don't ever think I'm
trying to convince you to do it like me
I'm not one of these people in there
trying to look at me and do it like me
by the system there's no system it's
just constant effort
constant alright d-roc you've been home
really sleeping for a while
I'm just finished up my hustle heading
home left o'clock at night
twelve favored nation